hey guys Pete here this is gonna be my
mr. robot season 3 episode 3 recap and
review I have to say that I really
enjoyed this episode and something weird
happened because I don't live in the
United States anymore I have to wait
longer to actually watch the episodes at
the wait till the end in the US and I
get all these notifications as I've
notifications for mr. robot obviously
since I I'm always looking into what's
going on with the series and I happen to
read a couple of the beginnings of a
couple of reviews before I started
watching and they were terrible they
were saying it was a horrible episode
that didn't need to exist and they
couldn't understand why it was necessary
and I try to avoid doing that because it
can affect the way that my experience is
and that's really all I have to offer is
my experience of watching the episode
I'm not anything more than a fan I just
make my videos based on what I observe
as someone who nerds out on these series
and I enjoyed this episode on a lot of
levels if you're into the series like I
am you've been wondering what happened
in those three days Tyrel is a bit of a
polarizing character some people love
him and some people hate him but I think
overall this episode fixed his character
for me like the problems I had with it
have been resolved now he may have no
investment in that storyline you might
only care about Elliott and that would
be understandable but it to not really
think this episode was important you'd
have to overlook the idea that Elliott
has been obsessed through the entirety
of season 2 but trying to figure out
what happened in those days he can't
remember so I feel like it was a big
payoff and there were several other ones
in the episode as well so let's look at
what actually happened the episode was
called EPS 3.2 legacy so we expected it
to be a flashback and it was exactly
that it mostly covered what happened at
the arcade how a vine got injected into
the story and where Tyrell went and
managed to be able to not be arrested as
the most wanted man in America for that
period of time in relation to that we
learned that Irving did show up and he
explains pretty clearly why he's there
because Elliott had messed up the dark
Carmi was monitoring what was happening
with the five nine hack and they
realized they had to intervene swiftly
because of Tyrells involvement we found
out how Elliot ended up in the car
although there's still more missing time
that we don't know about that's
something we need to keep in mind for
later but he was sent there by Irving
and then Irving took Tyrell to a safe
house that was heavily secured and then
just brought him the support he needed
so that he could remain there and not be
arrested
so everything mentions to him that he
could put him in contact with Johanna
through secure means if that's what he
wants to do and Tyrell in a very Tyrell
fashion decides that that would not be
the smartest move now he just had a
child his wife has basically said that
she doesn't want him around if he can't
fix their situation so this is a
difficult thing for a man to go through
we see that he gets to watch his child
through a baby cam and that he reads
about all the stuff that we saw happen
in season two as far as her filing for
divorce and all of the tabloid press and
everything else that went along that we
backtracked to the arcade I think what I
found interesting about that sequence
other than just what happened was that
I've always enjoyed the parallels that
Sam s Mel makes with the other
characters in relation to Elliot they're
all a bit damaged but in very different
ways I thought this was great in the
beginning of season two when we focused
in on the character ray and his
loneliness and Dom and her loneliness
obviously three different people three
different stations in life but all
basically struggling with that same deal
here we find out why Tyrell actually
makes sense for this story we saw him
lose just about everything in relation
to the mistake he made with Sharon
Knowles we saw Joanna lay out for him
flatly that she didn't want him around
anymore and that she wouldn't let him
see his son if he didn't fix the
situation when he gets fired after she
tells him that that pretty much screws
any chance he had
to do things normally so even though
we've seen that he's obsessed with power
and that he's very capable at doing the
whole executive corporate ladder we
actually learned what mr. robot sees in
his desperation how he can be useful
Irving is great I love the character I
love the way he's portrayed and it makes
total sense how he ended up there and
how Tyrell ended up where he was in the
process of showing us how he gets
through that period of time which
includes a lot of chopping wood and a
misguided thought of trying to leave the
compound for a period of time which ends
up in a whole nother rabbit hole the
important thing we learned here is that
Tyrell is absolutely bound to this idea
of what Elliott can do and he's bound in
a way that someone who doesn't have
anything else like this is his
last-ditch effort and he's going to go
down with the ship if necessary the
interview scene I thought was fun it was
maybe a little bit over the top that the
guy seemed to be snorting coke while I
was doing but I mean I enjoyed it
I thought it was funny I thought it was
very interesting the way that it was
shot and the way that he broke down as
viewers we knew that he hated his father
we knew that he killed Sharon Knowles
and so on but the process of breaking
him down was enjoyable to watch we
learned about White Rose a lot more and
the social commentary involved with this
I think was just thought on we see that
the Alex Jones type is being funded to
pass misinformation I mean that's
basically the media world we live in
right now we see the White Rose is ready
to back Trump and that is pretty spot-on
for where everything went I would say
and we learned that she has an island or
lives on has a house on an island that
is completely off the radar it doesn't
even show up on Google Maps which is
pretty cool when you think about it so
what else did we learn we learned what
we thought already which was that
Santiago is indeed in bed with the dark
army he kills the cop and rescues Tyrell
we find out that Irving
definitely as the car salesman through
and through he games Tyrell about family
and we get that little shot of the
number one dad coffee cup and all that
afterwards which I honestly laughed
pretty loudly whenever that happened I
think my neighbors probably heard me
laughing at that one and then one of the
big things that really stands out to me
is that we learn at the end through
Tyrell and Angela's talk that Angela may
have known about this disorder that
Elliot has for a very long time we saw
this in previous episodes this season
where she talks directly to mr. robot
that's something that may have existed
but from before Elliot even really knew
what was going on if you remember season
1 he starts out not remembering and I
think this is really interesting there's
always this talk about things that we
might have missed in season 1 I don't
know from my personal point of view the
idea about him not remembering Darlene
is something that I never really tied
together with mr. robot mr. robot always
seems like he appeared at first at that
time of course after the fact you start
to think well maybe he's been around
forever and there's plenty of theories
about when he might have emerged and all
of that but I think that that's
something that we really have to take
into consideration here is that that
period of not remembering Darlene also
has a lot to do with mr. robot and there
could be a whole relationship that
exists that we don't really know about
yet we knew Leon was working with the
dark army we found out how that actually
worked
we saw Elliot go to jail we saw how that
fit into the timeline of what going was
going on with Tyrell the detail and the
callbacks are just great I think I mean
there was all these little things that
didn't quite make sense and that we've
speculated on endlessly and in this one
episode a lot of those things tie back
together and they make sense of course
I'll do my things you might have missed
video later so I won't dwell on that too
much but I think this is just a really
satisfying episode for fans critics
might not like it bands that are
hell-bent on getting answers to what's
going to happen in
big picture might not like it but I
think for those of us and I think
because you're watching this video it's
a good chance you're in that Club there
are just so many little aha moments
throughout I really enjoyed that I can't
really spin it in a negative way I mean
I end I was happy I was excited about
the series and you know whatever maybe
that's a not a popular opinion but
that's the way I felt whenever I got
done with it the music was great I mean
some of the stuff I it was Gordon
Lightfoot that was going on for part of
it there and then it sort of cuts into
Cypress Hill the background music was
good as well like there you know the
music that was going on and how it stops
whenever the interviewer closes the book
I don't know I'm interested to see what
you guys think the gun stuff all makes
sense I know I think that was all pretty
self-explanatory I don't think we really
need to dwell on that I think we all got
the idea what happened there it'll be
interesting to see if Joanna wellick
plays a part beyond her death in the
second episode it'll be interesting to
see if she's in some flashbacks going
forward I'm much more interested in
Angelo's relationship with Eliot in the
past than I have been and I'm curious to
see where some of the comments that
she's made to him about being younger
together will play out later on the last
bit there we saw Eliot all drugged up
after surgery and we see mr. robot
flicker it briefly makes me think back
to times when maybe Elliott was actually
operating as mr. robot but as far as
taking Tyrell to the arcade that doesn't
seem to be the case at all mr. robot
seems to be surprised that he's there
and he wants to kill him of course call
it divine intervention if you're looking
through the lens that Tyrell was at that
time that didn't happen and you know
Irving tells us later what the problem
was and takes care of it so yeah I'm
excited I can't wait to do the trailer
breakdown tomorrow and then dig back and
look at all these different little
callbacks and think more about what a
novel called beach towel is actually
about the book that Irving's writing
that was a nice touch I think and what
what the hell else is white
rose up too I mean the Frank Cody thing
is pretty big I think like we saw Gideon
die as a result of that information
which is obviously something that has
been horrible for Elliot our main
character in a process I mean that was
his fault but white rose and his
disinformation campaign seems to have
played a big part in that as well so
that's about it for this please let me
know what you thought please let me know
if he hated it why did you hate it if
you loved it why did you love it what
was the biggest moment for you the
biggest reveal out of so many please
like the video if you enjoyed it make
sure you subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already you'll want to turn on
notifications after you do that so you
know when my new videos come out follow
me on Twitter that's where I'm most
active and I keep Instagram and Facebook
page as well so follow those if you
prefer those and thanks for watching
guys I'll talk to you soon